one of the things we've really been
trying to figure out is what is the real
rate of corona virus infection because
the official numbers only tell us the
number of people that have actually had
a test and tested positive for the
disease but of course there's a whole
bunch of people who have or have had
corona virus without being tested many
of whom have already recovered and one
of the ways you can test for the real
rate is to do an antibody test
antibodies produced by the body in the
process of or after finishing the
process of fighting the virus but there
have been antibody tests that have not
been accurate so that has not been
particularly useful there have also been
studies that have tested sewage and
depending on which test you look at
we've heard that the real infection rate
could be as small as 2 times the
official rate or as large as 250 times
the official rate now I've said before
only two times the official rate sounds
low to me 250 times the official rate
sounds too high to me if it were 250
times the official rate we'd be talking
about roughly 200 million Americans with
corona virus and that does not seem to
pass the sniff test although if it were
true we would potentially be close to
herd immunity but it doesn't pass the
sniff test so in looking at different
data my thought has been the real number
of infections is somewhere between four
and thirty times the official number
which is still a very big range we have
a new study from Los Angeles County that
is looking at exactly this question what
is the real rate of infection they went
and they gave antibody tests to a random
sample of 863 adults and they found that
somewhere between two hundred and twenty
thousand and four hundred and forty
thousand people in Los Angeles County
have already been infected now when you
compare those numbers to the official
case number of just under fourteen
thousand at the time that the study was
done this study implies that the real
infection number is somewhere between
fifteen and thirty times the official
case number now if we apply that to the
entire United States it would suggest
between 12 and 24 million people have or
have had coronavirus so far or really
have had because you don't have
antibodies when you're actively infected
now as always there's a bunch of caveats
here one is no one study is likely to be
the one infection rates are
realistically different in different
different parts of the country and
importantly even if this is correct we
would be nowhere near herd immunity at
this point in time the good news if the
real rate of infection is 15 to 30 times
the official rate is it implies a far
lower fatality rate than we think
because a much smaller portion of people
are dying if you have a thousand deaths
out of 10,000 infections that's much
more serious than if you have a thousand
deaths out of a hundred thousand
infections now the bad news of the real
rate being 15 to 30 times the official
rate is that it means the virus spreads
way more easily than we thought and we
are nowhere near having a testing system
that can actually identify a large
portion of the cases if you can't
identify cases you can't contact trace
you can't tell people who might have
been exposed that they need to
quarantine but as always any one study
can be way off we've learned that some
antibody tests are just very inaccurate
at fundamentally technically speaking I
believe some of those tests may have
been used in this study the other thing
to keep in mind is the more you test the
closer you are to the real infection
rate so I want to be really clear about
this we can't just take the the
nationwide number and multiply it by 15
to 30 based on the LA County results why
not I'll give you an example
New York is testing way more than
California New York has tested 33,000
people for every million in the
population whereas California has only
tested 7,000 people for every million in
the population since California has not
been testing as much as New York
we would imagine that the real infection
rate in California is many times higher
than the real infection rate in New York
because New York has tested more people
that's what we know right now someday
we'll have a good antibody test we can
rely on we'll figure out what the real
penetrance of the disease has been
across the country we're not there yet
and the reality that we have right now
is we are certainly under counting cases
we just don't know exactly by how much
one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you $5.00 when you sign
up for their completely free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a ten dollar a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more but definitely go ahead
and at least get started with the free
plan you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at privacy
comm slash Pakman